are you guys down to go golfing we've
been golfing with you so many times we
went to the driving range oh
yeah are we gonna piss everyone off
because how long no that's why we're
gonna do the night golfing at Monterey
Park it's only nine holes in part three
we can't even film that it's all
dark yeah
what about what else you got I'll shoot
it down why don't we go to Vegas
and then we don't have to go to one
that's because I'm not gonna go to 18
hole Par Four with you guys and just be
chasing balls in the woods the whole
time for five hours why not that sounds
kind of fun though oh my friend lives on
a golf course we'll just go to his
backyard open the gate and we can start
playing as free f-r-e-e are we sure it's
free
hahaha